[Music]
thank you
hello and welcome to our favorite
program I'd like to know this is a
program that allows us to answer your
questions from the word of God he gives
us another excuse to do that which we
like to do in that study the word of God
and dive into the word of God in an
attempt to answer your questions from
that very same word of God and of course
we make you this promise that when you
send in your questions we will answer
them from God's holy word that will be
our pledge to you that will use the
Bible tell you the truth the whole truth
and nothing but the truth in these last
days we need to hear a word from the
Lord and that's what we promised by the
grace of God to give you I say we I'm in
the company of Pastor Stephen Bohr to my
left Pastor good to have you here it is
a delightful experience to be here for
this program it is my favorite activity
indeed and Pastor Daniel Miranda to my
right Pastor is always good to have you
here it is always good to be here also
sharing this wonderful panel with
wonderful people
and we praise the Lord uh the rumors are
true we do like each other we enjoy each
other's company we endure enjoy studying
the word of God together so yes there is
a rumor out that we like each other well
let me confirm the rumor the rumor is
true and we praise the Lord for that now
should you want to get in on the fun and
we encourage you to do so you can email
us at TV at some TV that's s-u-m as in
Mary
tv.org TV at some tv.org you write your
questions you send in your questions
Dare ideas dare say you call in your
questions we will take them down we will
add them to this impressive pile of
questions that we have and we will get
to them we promise you we are wading
through sometimes we get through two
sometimes three sometimes four every now
and again five questions on the program
but we we don't like to rush through
them we want to give answers and
sometimes uh they're not yes or no
answers they've got to be explained and
you've got to give some history and some
biblical understanding so it takes a
little time to work our way through the
questions and we promise that we will do
that and we thank you for your patience
but we will get to your questions uh and
uh we thank you for your patience Pastor
Daniel if you would open this program in
prayer then we can begin and then pass
the board after uh Daniel prays we've
got a little uh dangling participle from
the last program that we wanted to just
tie up and we'll give you a chance to do
that so Daniel let's pray if you will
let's buy a heads for prayer dear
heavenly father we thank you for this
new program of I like to know thank you
for those who are sending their
questions and for those who have been
transformed through these programs and I
just pray Lord that as we delve into the
word of God that we may have the
guidance of the Holy Spirit we
understand that things spiritual things
are spiritually discerned so give us a
spiritual mind as we open up your word
in the name of Jesus we pray amen amen
and amen amen pastor we had a little
something left over from a previous
program that you want to take a little
uh time with yeah just very briefly
um we were answering three questions
last time in our last program and one of
those questions from Samson uh was
concerning dinosaurs
uh and uh you know in the question he
states that the dinosaurs pre-date or
pre-exist the first man which uh you
know there's no evidence that the
Dinosaurs pre-existed the first man
those who believe in the ruin and
reconstruction theory that I mentioned
in the last program might believe that
but there's no clear evidence either in
the Bible or the spirit of prophecy on
that point if you want to know more
about dinosaurs we had one program where
we dealt with that and that program was
May 5
so if you go to our archives of some TV
if you download the app you'll be able
to find that program and see what we
have to say about dinosaurs so I hope
that you will check that out May 5 2020.
alrighty very good and thank you for
that uh
the new app allows us to do that kind of
research you know just to put in a uh a
commercial for the new app it allows you
to go back and research some things in a
more thorough way than ever before so
you can go back and find out
informations find questions find answers
find programs that deal with the a
specific subject and uh it makes that
new app fun and very very useful uh to
us today
already it's the next one Kempton
actually it's Jason at the end
that's it that's the same one but uh he
calls himself oh yeah okay from Captain
it becomes Dead
all right depending on where you're
looking Jason in Kempton oh very good
already this is my second question I am
an SDA Center dentist
someone got up in church and made a
statement that we are not Sinners but
children of God
I began to think on it as I looked
through the Bible and the spirit of
Prophecy I
as soon as referred to as outside
of Christ and those who are unrepentant
I see those who are rebellious and do
not look at the cross except Christ
to accept Christ's righteousness I don't
want to dwell on the topic if it is
biblically incorrect what I am thinking
or even should I dwell on is there a
simple yes or no answer to the question
well there is no simple yes or no answer
to the question because you've got to
understand righteousness by faith and
justification by faith so right
answering the question has asked there's
there's no simple yes or no because you
need to explain this doctrine of
righteousness by faith
um so let's let's wade into that
yes well the Theology of sin is very
complex and in our church
Scholars are divided into what sin is or
sinfulness or sinful nature
but it is true that
first of all that when we accept Christ
we are accounted righteous in Jesus
Christ so but
let me before what before I say what I
was going to say let me go to First John
chapter 1 verse 8 and then verse 10.
because here we find a clear answer to
this
um I haven't studied these texts
how the tensions in the in the Greek may
be Passover can help us with that
but here I see in verse 8 it's talking
about the present but verse 10 is in
past
and verse 8 says if we say that we have
no sin present
we deceive ourselves and the truth is
not in US
then verse 10 says if we say that we
have not sinned
we make him a liar and his word is not
in US
so verse 8 tells us about our present
condition
if we say we have no sin in other words
if we say we don't have a sinful nature
we deceive ourselves and the truth is
not in us if we say that we have not
sinned
we make him a liar and his word is not
in us who has not ever sinned before so
um
yes we we may we may have a sinful
nature
but we are sinners not by Nature we are
Sinners by choice
yes
um you know there is a very interesting
verse in Isaiah chapter six that I think
frames this
um
it's the call of Isaiah in Isaiah
chapter 6. and uh when he beholds the
absolute Holiness of God
he feels undone
this is the great prophet Isaiah the
gospel prophet Isaiah
and uh it says in verse 3 and one cried
to another the seraphim holy holy holy
is the Lord of hosts the whole earth is
full of his glory and the posts of the
door were shaken by the voice of him who
cried out and the house was filled with
smoke so what happens when Isaiah
beholds the absolute Holiness of God uh
verse 5 says so I said woe is me for I
am undone
because I am a man of unclean lips
and I dwell in the midst of a people of
unclean lips for my eyes have seen the
king the Lord of hosts you know when I
was in the Seminary I had a teacher his
name was Karsten Johnson we carry some
of his books here
um I think he had like three doctorates
super humble guy I mean he had this
self-supporting institution in France he
passed away several years ago I took as
many classes as I could from him and uh
he had a saying saying I think you got
it from Luther
simul picature simul penitencia
and basically what that means at the
time same time sinner at the same time
righteous because at the same time
you're repentant
and and there's truth to that because we
will be Sinners till Jesus comes
but at the same time we'll be righteous
not in ourselves but righteous in him
amen we are accepted in the Beloved
his righteousness counts counts in place
of our unrighteousness
that is our status
but then as we mentioned in one of the
previous programs Jesus not only reckons
Us in him
but he also pours into our heart the
holy spirit so that we can live a life
that is that is a reflection of his life
yes and so uh you know are we still
Sinners after we accept Christ yes are
we righteous yes because of his
righteousness not because of ours uh you
know the Apostle Paul is the great
Apostle of the uh of righteousness by
faith yes and yet in first Timothy uh
chapter 1 and verse 15 uh it's very
interesting what he had to say in first
Timothy chapter 1 and verse 15 uh the
Apostle Paul wrote this
um did I say 115
yeah first Timothy 1 and verse 15.
or is it second Timothy
okay it's first Timothy here it is
um
this is a faithful saying and worthy of
all acceptance yes that Christ Jesus
came into the world to save Sinners of
whom I am chief
not was Chief and chief because he was a
sinner you know
one example is uh when he got angry at
Barnabas because he wanted to take John
Mark on a trip with him he kind of lost
it and he was really harsh on John Mark
so so that's after his conversion but
I'm sure he he repented in fact the
spirit of Prophecy tells us he repented
yes and later on Mark became very useful
in the Lord's cause so so at the same
time even though we are sinful
we are reckoned righteous in Christ yes
so you know Seymour used to simul
pecators simul penitencia in other words
if you're penitent or if you're
repentant then God looks upon you as
righteous we can never look at ourselves
as being righteous and the only one that
can
make an estimate of our own condition is
even Jesus Christ the first time the
very moment that I say I am not a sinner
then I am sinning
because I'm lying but here John said he
is a liar and the truth is not in him uh
that doesn't mean because that
expression is so complex it can be
easily misunderstood that doesn't mean
that because I say we say we are sinners
then we are openly sinning all the time
right that that's a different thing but
when it comes to our condition and and
uh and nature and sinfulness
good a couple of things uh John in in uh
alluding to your point Pastor uh says
that those who are in Christ do not sin
and he says that three times in first
second and third John yes he says that
in three separate places and of course
it can confuse you until you realize
that that that the lesson is in the
um is a linear verb in the oh my
goodness
um it's in the tense that means to start
and continue
um having uh of having us as they call a
senior moment but it but what it is
saying is
is that those who are in Christ do not
continue to sin do not wallow in sin do
not continue to live in sin
um
so it's in the ah it's just out of my
brain
um but I wanted to come back because
whenever I I think about righteousness
and justification of our faith my mind
automatically goes back to the same book
that Luther got it from and that's the
book of Romans and so I want to just
give you something really quick from
Romans chapter four uh which deals with
Abraham being just justified by faith
and then in verse 23
it says uh now was not written for his
sake alone that is Abraham's that it was
imputed to him but for but also for us
so the same way Abraham is accounted
righteous we are accounted righteous uh
it shall be imputed to us who believe in
him who raised up Jesus uh
our Lord from the dead so we we are
counted righteous because of our our
belief in Christ and righteousness is
imputed to us while the Holy Spirit is
actually actively working in our lives
to make us better each day we get credit
for being righteous uh so basically
God's got us covered for and aft you
know he accounts us righteous and then
he sets about making us righteous and uh
that's the beauty of righteousness by by
faith you know there's a beautiful
promise uh that we find in first John
what you read from first John chapter 2
and verse 1. my little children when he
says my little children he's talking to
Believers people who've accepted Christ
my little children these things are
right to you so that you may not sin
and if anyone sins
we have an advocate with the father
Jesus Christ the righteous
and he himself is the propitiation for
our sins and not for hours only but also
for the whole world so here uh John is
recognizing that uh you know he writes
to us so that we don't sin but if we sin
and we truly repent yes and confess our
sin and trust in Jesus Jesus will
forgive our sins and he will cleanse us
from all unrighteousness as he promises
in uh chapter 1 and verse 9. well said
so uh you know don't despair if after
you've accepted Christ and become a
child of God uh you are disobedient to
the Lord you know my children who were
disobedient many times as I was of my
parents that doesn't mean that it wasn't
their child you know doesn't mean that I
said that I didn't say that I was sorry
and they forgave and we moved on and so
uh children of God uh unfortunately in a
sinful World many times sin it doesn't
justify the act of sin yes but if we sin
and we're truly sorry then jesus takes
his righteousness and credits it to our
account yeah Christ has got it all
covered it's the imperfect tense the
imperfect sense is something that starts
and continues uh the imperfect so if God
says those who are in Christ do not sin
then how does it say and if we sin we've
got to Advocate with the father right so
it sounds like God is speaking out of
both sides of his mouth but he's not
he's saying those who are in Christ do
not live in sin do not go back to sin do
not wallow in sin but if you make a
mistake if your foot slips uh you've got
someone to take care of that even Jesus
Christ the righteous who is The Advocate
with with the father so so it's
beautiful beautiful doctrine of
righteousness and Justice justification
amen by faith amen all righty
um now let's go to
finished
I'm looking at both names now is this
quacher yes
and we thank you for your questions this
is someone outside the United States
we're looking at the phone 077 so I'm
not sure exactly where that is but uh we
praise the Lord for that uh question for
the pastor is there reference in the
Bible or the spirit of prophecy on the
high priest having ropes to pull him out
of the most holy place when he dies
inside or she means inside the most holy
place or is it just uh
proposal by commentators okay so is this
something that's verified in the Bible
or Spirit of Prophecy or is it just sort
of commentary that uh is is uh sort of
out there in the uh popular culture
this comes this comes from the Apocrypha
of Ellen White volume one
chapter of the book of hesitation yeah
you know I've heard this time and again
I've had this question asked wherever I
go
um many many times
and I have not found anything in the
spirit of Prophecy to to uh
support this idea that they put a rope
around the high priest so that if he was
not right with the Lord they would have
to pull him out from the most holy place
and I have not found anything in Jewish
sources either uh to this effect
it might be there but I have not been
able to find it and I don't know of any
scholar that has been able to find it
I don't know Daniel do you know well
I've read that Leslie Harding he he
quotes and makes allusion to this but I
don't do not recall from her he quotes
or he just repeats the the same
tradition but I do recall that he
mentions it but I do not recall if he
gives the reference to where he took it
from it would be nice to find the
reference that Leslie Harding makes to
see if it really comes from a source
yeah he might be quoting a source that
quoted a source that quoted a source
you know it's it's been around so long
and it's it's almost just in the air
that we breathe I remember hearing about
this years ago and you hear about it so
much you almost believe it's got to be
someplace because so many people uh
recite it and you hear it so often but I
cannot think of a place in particular
that I could point to that that says
that even Spirit of Prophecy I want to
say you know maybe I have but I can't I
cannot play place it so
it's we haven't found it uh truth be
told it has not been found and if
someone has something definite we would
certainly like to accept it and like to
see it and uh we'd bring it to the
program in a future program and talk
about it but I have not seen anything
Pastor has not seen anything uh and
Pastor Daniel has not seen anything per
se nor can we refer to a text in the
Bible it is not there yeah uh there may
be something in some obscure letter and
spirit of Prophecy that we don't know
about but um uh we have not seen it so
they have not read it in the Hispanic
World there are
um many apocryphal statements of Ellen
White that are used like for example
entire churches with their pastors are
going to be lost yes yes there's no
nowhere in the spirit blessing that says
that or uh you know everybody's going to
have to keep one Sabbath before we get
to heaven and those are things you grow
up with you know entire conferences are
going to be lost the last work of Jesus
Christ in the Heavenly Century will be
to answer the prayers of the mothers for
their children children yeah right yeah
these things sound good they make you
feel good but they they have no basis in
in scripture and uh in the spirit of
Prophecy uh I remember years ago there
was a statement that uh uh about Ellen
White uh in prayer and it was printed up
and very very nice and and we went to
the the I don't know what I said and
they said we cannot find that statement
anywhere beautiful statement but if we
couldn't find it it doesn't exist
so we praise the Lord so if if you have
knowledge of of this particular truth
that we do not have we'd be glad to
receive it and take a look at that but
as of this date uh in the history of
this Earth we do not have it we do not
see it already
very good we've got time for just a
little bit more Daniel what's our next
question yeah this question is more this
comes from jariela Ponte and this
question is more a recommendation or a
favor that he is asking us a brother he
wants some books that we recommend to
him some books about the history of the
Christian Church uh beginning in the
first century besides the great
controversy I recently took a class and
there is a good book there's two volumes
it's called history of Christianity by
justo Gonzalez he's Cuban and it is in
English I haven't found a copy in
Spanish but it's really good very
detailed with uh up-to-date information
sources that I had not read before he
has done a thorough research on the
history of Christianity and he does a
pretty good job
now La Tourette also has a history of
the Christian Church from beginning to
end
you know
it would actually
be best to read great controversy yeah I
know he's asking for sources other than
the great conference you know you have
diabigny for the history of
protestantism you have Wiley's work you
know there's a four volume set on the
history of the pros what led up to the
Protestant Reformation and so on but the
genius of the book The Great controversy
is that it is not a history
it is a philosophy of History yes
because you know historians basically
they can conjecture you know about why
this happened and why that happened but
but really a historian simply repeats
what is visible to to the naked eye you
know this happened in a certain place at
a certain time in a certain way with
certain individuals uh that's what all
the historian can write but Ellen White
takes us behind the veil yes and she
tells us the motivating forces the work
that Christ is doing through his angels
and the work that Satan is doing through
his angels to try and prevent Jesus from
doing what he wants to do and so Ellen
White helps us see history behind the
veil yes whereas historians can only
tell us what is uh visible to this naked
eye yes it is a retrospector I think you
you said it very well but between God
and man and God's interplay with man and
the insertion of heavenly intelligences
into the life and history of mankind so
the view is much broader and steps back
and sees it in its much broader context
as what God is doing now I would also
like to answer that book the
Encyclopedia of Western churches I don't
recall who responds a big white book uh
very very thick and it gives you the
history of each church as it
evolves and and where it came from so
there's much out there but I I would
agree with you Pastor to recommend the
great controversy because the the
perspective is so difficult yes oh yes
yeah yeah before you go to any other
history book you need to read the great
controversy because it gives you the
perspective there is another book in the
same line of the great controversy but
it's of course is not inspired it's
called Truth triumphant by Vijay
Wilkinson yes and he takes a revelation
12 and he basically bases his entire
book on Revelation 12 and the history of
the church in the wilderness and the
different stages and it's very wonderful
book but I think the foundation for him
writing that book was inspired by the
great economy yes
um you know also the the works by shaf
wrote a lot about the history of
Christianity and so all you have to do
is uh Google Shaft or La Tourette and uh
you'll find uh histories of Christianity
these are older histories of
Christianity than the one probably that
was recommended in your recent class but
uh just look look up Google uh volumes
on the history of Christianity and
you'll find many many sources yeah
there's much written about uh the
history of Christianity so it really
depends on what you're particularly
looking for how you want to attack it
but I think if you start with a great
controversy again it's it's a matter of
perspective you can put all of these
other histories in perspective because
you've got the overall picture by
looking at the great controversy I find
every time I read the very controversy
and through not maybe half a dozen times
or so
um since my perspective on life changes
and grows it grows with me so I see
something new that I didn't see was that
there before oh yeah with that there you
would just you weren't there at that
point in time so as you grow that book
will grow with you and it's a it's a
wonderful wonderful wonderful uh book uh
to read over and over again uh and a
great work the last several chapters are
almost like reading the newspaper these
days very much so yeah the last six
chapters or so are very much like
reading the newspaper very very much so
well again gentlemen our our time has
has um gone by and we are so thankful
that you have joined us for this
particular sitting and we pray that what
we have discussed has been meet in due
season for you and uh we'll encourage
you as together we walk this road that
leads to Glory as I always say our time
has fast slipped into eternity allow me
now on closing to wish you both Grace
and peace through our Lord and Savior
Jesus Christ we'll see you again soon
bye bye and God bless
foreign
[Music]